hola bienvenidos a una nueva emisión de
la entrevista de france 24 hoy vamos a
hablar del acoso y de la violencia
escolar a propósito de un caso
emblemático que hace años acudió a
colombia y que acaba de tener un nuevo
episodio en la justicia con una condena
que muchas personas consideran histórica
un caso que tuvo lugar en colombia pero
que habla de una problemática que excede
las fronteras del país en agosto de 2014
el joven colombiana sergio urrego tenía
16 años cuando decidió quitarse la vida
en bogotá a la capital colombiana
su muerte ocurrió luego de haber sufrido
discriminación constante persecuciones y
violencia por parte de las autoridades
del colegio donde estudiaba y esto por
su orientación sexual el pasado 30 de
abril un juez colombiano condenó a diez
años y ocho meses de prisión a amanda a
su cena a castillo ex directora del
colegio gimnasio castillo campestre el
colegio donde estudiaba a sergio fue
hallada responsable de los delitos de
falsa denuncia contra persona
determinada también de ocultamiento y
alteración o destrucción de elementos
materiales probatorios una decisión que
no obstante podría ser apelada por su
defensa salud
y agradecemos muchísimo su presencia en
france 24 a alba reyes ella es la mamá
de sergio regó alba muchísimas gracias
por su presencia en france 24
no muchas gracias a ti y muchas gracias
al canal por esta invitación bueno
recién hacía un repaso por la trágica
historia de sergio pero para comenzar le
pido por supuesto con todo el respeto y
hasta donde usted quiera y pueda avanzar
un repaso por el origen de todo su hijo
sergio mantenía una relación con un
compañero de colegio las autoridades de
esta institución
violentaron absolutamente su intimidad
verdad a partir de allí comenzó todo un
camino de acoso de discriminación y de
vulneración absoluta de sus derechos
y así es mi hijo sergio y luego en ese
momento tenía 16 años de edad mi hijo
siempre se caracterizó por ser uno de
los mejores estudiantes desde muy
pequeño
era muy brillante mi hijo le gustaba
muchísimo leer la literatura me dejó
varios escritos dentro de esos escritos
pues también dejó muchísimas evidencias
de lo que claramente se está estaba
pasando en su colegio y además que
después cuando él simplemente se da un
pico con su con su pareja dentro del
colegio le acarrea una serie de
persecuciones por parte de las
directivas de la psicóloga de la
coordinadora de su colegio y de los
docentes de una manera sistemática
dentro de estas persecuciones se
encontraron también pues
a mí como madre me exigían presentas
presentar certificados psicológicos de
mi hijo cuando pues claramente esto no
es válido y no es permitido por el
derecho a la intimidad a la intimidad de
los jóvenes de los niños y las niñas y
claramente empezó una persecución
también hacia a mí como su madre porque
pues se evidenció claramente que hubo
una paz un apoyo incondicional hacia él
yo quise abrazar a mi hijo en ese
momento porque también fue obligado a
que me contara acerca de su orientación
sexual algo que tampoco es viable y
permitido cada persona tiene derecho de
hablar acerca de su orientación sexual
en el momento que así lo considere y
asimismo mi hijo fue desescolarizados
hasta no presentar
continuamente los certificados escolares
igualmente los certificados psicológicos
discúlpame igualmente
cuando estaba portas de ingresar porque
esto pasa antes de sus vacaciones de
mitad de año cuando ya estaba portal de
ingresar nos citan a una reunión donde
claramente fue una de las pruebas más
contundentes yo grabé esta reunión y la
presenté como evidencia porque
claramente amanda su cena
ahí se trata de inculpar a sergio por un
haz y por un supuesto acoso sexual
contra otro niño que pues claramente era
su pareja y en lo cual pues no era
cierto era una relación consensuada y
desde ahí se desarrollan una serie de
hechos sistemáticos como eso una falsa
denuncia ante la fiscalía de menores acá
en colombia por acoso sexual y además de
esto mi hijo pues fue discriminado
en todo el sentido de la palabra ni
siquiera solamente por su orientación
sexual sino también hasta por su forma
de pensar y de actuar
alva cuando se habla de acoso escolar en
general se apunta a la violencia entre
padres no entre compañeros sin embargo
en el caso de sergio la violencia vino
por parte de las propias autoridades de
los adultos de quienes debían velar por
su seguridad no por su bienestar
si claramente esto pasó
sí como tú lo dices casi siempre cuando
hablamos de bully matón yo siempre
hablamos de los jóvenes de los de la
discriminación también entre jóvenes
este fue un caso que desde el 2014
inclusive en argentina fue estudiado
precisamente por las escuelas de
bullying y mcconnell donde se evidenció
muy claro que son también los adultos
los que empiezan a discriminar los que
hablan desde su prejuicio los que
señalan y educan también a otras
generaciones desde sus propios miedos no
porque esto realmente y claramente es un
miedo que tiene la sociedad de
confrontarse a sí misma y de confrontar
a los seres humanos sin etiquetas
entonces yo sí creo que
el caso y el caso de mi hijo
precisamente ha evidenciado que cómo se
aprende a discriminar desde los adultos
cómo se aprende a discriminar desde la
casa
absolutamente bueno como informábamos al
comienzo de la entrevista alva quien
fuera en aquel momento la rectora del
colegio hablamos de amanda a su escena
castillo fue condenada a diez años y
ocho meses de prisión esto podrá ser
apelado no por su defensa pero como
recibió el fallo tras tantos años de
lucha
bueno mira son sentimientos muy
encontrados porque estos últimos
audiencias en estas últimas audiencias
ha sido demasiado difíciles para mí y
tuve que escuchar testigos y testimonios
tan claros como lo de su misma pareja a
quien no veía desde que ocurrió lo que
ocurrió sentir el dolor del también
sentir como también sufrió muchísimo en
ese momento como sus padres fueron
coaccionados para que le colocaran esta
falsa denuncia a mi hijo a cambio de que
se pudiera graduar en el colegio como
sistemáticamente una persona puede
hacerle tanto daño a dos niños en ese
momento porque eran dos niños dos
jóvenes de 16 años que lo único que
querían en su momento era graduarse que
tenían un proyecto de vida
escuchar a los padres de danilo escuchar
a su madre también su dolor por todo lo
que tuvo que haber vivido en su momento
y como madre me uno también ese dolor
entonces pues bueno creo que este
resultado durante estos siete años de
audiencias ha sido más que un resultado
de cagarse lo castigo un resultado que
nos deja una gran enseñanza que es un
resultado que ha partido en la historia
en colombia porque estas tres condenas
porque ya había sido condenada la
psicóloga la coordinadora de su colegio
y pues hoy en día la rectora por los por
los delitos de falsa denuncia
ocultamiento de pruebas y discriminación
agravada en su momento realmente esto
deja un precedente un precedente de que
nunca más esto vuelva a ocurrir esto
deja un mensaje claro de la no
repetición de realmente conservar la
memoria de los jóvenes diversos en sus
escuelas y aquellos jóvenes que aún
siguen sufriendo en silencio
y de muchos casos que han llegado a
quitarse la vida como mi hijo pero que
pues muy seguramente han quedado ocultos
yo creo que es esto más el precedente
que se ha deja y así recibo esta
sentencia para mí
no es tan importante y consideró que las
cárceles no transforman pero sí las
forma un precedente en colombia si
transforma un ejemplo claro de que un
adulto y menos un adulto que se
encuentre dentro de los ámbitos
educativos puede juzgar desde su propio
prejuicio discriminar y violentar a
algún niño algún niño o algún joven por
su orientación sexual pero que si usted
transformó o le significó mejor dicho
ese dolor no porque le va a acompañar
por siempre en un impulso para ayudar a
los demás y creo la fundación sergio
áureo que trabaja precisamente en
prevención de la discriminación y el
suicidio motivado por discriminación en
todos los ámbitos académicos y el acoso
escolar es un tema del cual se suele
hablar
aunque quizás no tanto de los suicidios
que provoca verdad y que sin embargo es
una de las peores consecuencias de esa
violencia y los casos no son pocos
verdad
no realmente no yo sí abrí la fundación
sergio riego en el 2015 precisamente en
memoria de mi hijo y a través de estos
siete años que hemos trabajado
incansablemente en previsión a la no
discriminación y a la prevención del
suicidio de niños niñas y jóvenes en
ambientes escolares
realmente hemos tenido que evidenciar
qué
lastimosamente muchos jóvenes hoy en día
son personas latentes al suicidio a la
depresión
realmente lastimosamente tenemos que
decirlo así y de acuerdo a la
organización panamericana de la salud en
la segunda causa de mortalidad de los
jóvenes en el mundo es el suicidio y
trabajando a través de nuestra línea
salvavidas 24/7 la cual ya llevamos un
año y hemos atendido más de cuatro mil
personas en crisis nos hemos dado cuenta
que atrás de ese dolor atrás de esas y
de acciones atrás de esa depresión hay
un tema de discriminación no solamente
pues por temas de orientación sexual hay
muchísimos temas de discriminación
precisamente también por todo lo que
creamos allá afuera no creamos de
demasiados estereotipos para los jóvenes
y a veces ellos y ellas no saben dónde
encajar algo recibes muchísimas gracias
por su presencia en france 24 y el más
profundo deseo de que se continúe por el
camino de la justicia muchísimas gracias
a ustedes un abrazo enorme no por favor
a usted ya nuestra audiencia como
siempre invitamos a continuar informando
se en el resto de nuestra programación y
en france mit y cuatro.com
[Música]